foreign
in terms of running effective and
efficient meetings
I believe there are three types of
meetings
meeting one
is all verbal
these are the 99 of meetings are like
this and they're usually
really inefficient and everyone sort of
gets frustrated and the only people that
get to speak are the people who are
bolder and the people who are quieter
and more introverted don't even speak
and so we think they don't have anything
to say but it turns out they have a lot
to share and they also don't feel bought
in because they don't feel included in
the conversations
second type of meeting people
pre-write
this is where Amazon goes this is saying
if you want to bring something up in
this meeting you've got to write it out
and in the beginning of the meeting
we'll all read it and then we'll give
our opinions and we'll make a decision
those are much more effective meetings
because now we have real content that
can be shared and consumed and so the
conversation is not superficial the
conversation to render decision is on a
much deeper level
and then the most effective meetings is
the type 3 which is very difficult to
get to and that is people submit in
advance their
issues topics in writing but 24 hours in
advance
then in that last 24 hours all the
meeting participants read and comment on
all of that material
so that when the meeting starts we've
now gone one level two levels down and
the verbal portion is at the third and
much deeper level I now already know
what everybody thinks including the
people that are introverted and don't
like to speak up during a meeting
because they don't think you know
there's not that bold now I know
everybody's thoughts and now everybody
is actually bought in to whatever the
decision is because they participated in
it that's level three the company that
does this best is brex that I know of
and it requires a lot of
holding people accountable and if
someone does not enter their issue by
you know 24 hours before the exact team
meeting they don't get to enter it and
if people have not commented on the
issue by the time the meeting starts
they don't get to comment it's it's an
extreme version of accountability that
drives one time people will miss but
once they miss one time they are
absolutely prepared the next time
[Music]
so that to me is the quick and dirty
version yeah I love quick and dirty but
what percentage I'm just curious if
meetings get canceled once a document is
created and people add all of their
comments I know maybe like a precise
percentage not needed but do they still
tend to proceed with the meeting and
verbal portion of that or are there a
lot of cases where you know what we
didn't actually need a meeting this is
resolved what we needed to resolve
there's always a little bit of
synchronous time that's required because
again the writing doesn't
fully satisfy the communication
and so
at least Pedro I don't think Pedro Brax
is is canceling exact team meetings
because the issues and the comments are
so thorough is like got it got
everything I need like I don't need to
see you guys anymore that's not
happening it's let's do the final I've
heard senior comments now I'd like to
hear verbally you know you and you and
you please share your verbally okay now
I get it now I have my decision here's
my decision let me share it with you or
I'm going to appoint someone else to be
the decision maker but yeah the
synchronous portion is needed to sort of
finalize the decision to really make
people feel heard and then there's
another portion which cannot be done
asynchronously and that is feedback
because it's so dangerous to give
feedback asynchronously because if I
give you what I think is constructive
feedback and you get insulted or feel
defensive right and I don't see that or
I don't hear that then I can't say oh
Tim wait a second I didn't mean I meant
that with love I didn't mean to to make
you feel anger so if I'm not there to
catch it you'll feel anger towards me
and it doesn't get resolved
exactly and within a few days because of
confirmation bias you'll have already
amassed enough evidence
to prove that I'm the devil that our
relationship will be destroyed forever
and so feedback must be done I believe
in person and I also think that's a
critical component of successful
meetings give me feedback as manager let
me give give each other feedback as
peers I mean that doesn't it doesn't
even exist in most companies rarely do
people give feedback to the CEO but
almost never do people give feedback to
each other at the exact Team level yeah
very true so I introduced that certainly
brex does and almost all the companies I
coach do